out of all the nutrients that our body
needs potassium is at the very top of
the list as far as the huge requirements
we're talking 4 700 milligrams no other
nutrient comes even close to that now
the question is why why do we need so
much potassium because potassium
fulfills a very very important enzyme
that's involved in the sodium potassium
pump this pump is in all of your nerve
cells it's in all of your muscle cells
it is the pump that establishes the
battery of our cells we need this pump
to move electrical impulses we also need
this pump for muscle contraction that
are in your arteries we need it in the
heart for the heart muscle as well as in
your kidney and today we're going to
talk about the consequences of not
having enough potassium in our diet but
there's some new information I want to
share with you from a paper entitled
achieving the benefits of a high
potassium
Paleolithic diet without the toxic City
apparently thousands of years ago in the
Stone Age
humans have consumed a lot more than 4
700 milligrams in fact there's evidence
to show that humans consumed up to 15
000 milligrams of potassium every single
day that's four times the current rdas
which is still quite High 4 700 and then
if we look at the relationship of
potassium to sodium with those levels
we're talking 16 times more potassium
than sodium so there's some really
interesting incredible data the show
that we need even more potassium than we
really think and what backs that up is
the kidney our kidneys have a very
robust capacity to get rid of excess
potassium but not sodium but potassium
so sometimes people say that oh yeah
potassium is bad for the kidneys it can
create problems that's only in like
stage five kidney disease which is
end-stage kidney disease if you take
large amounts of potassium before you
get kidney disease it actually has been
shown to be protective against kidney
disease I mean the average person
consumes like 1.5 cups of vegetables
which are the primary source potassium
and no you're not going to get a lot of
potassium from bananas bananas have
roughly about 300 milligrams so you'd
have to eat a lot of bananas to get your
fulfillment of potassium and of course
bananas have a lot of fructose which
comes with other issues potatoes are
also supposed to have a lot of potassium
but of course the starch creates other
issues one medium-sized potato has about
600 milligrams of potassium but just one
cup of leafy greens is between
500 to 800 milligrams that's one cup and
if you consumed like five seven or even
10 cups well that would give you a
tremendous amount of potassium the point
is we need a lot of potassium we
probably need more than we're consuming
unfortunately the average person is not
consuming enough potassium from the diet
and you might say well maybe they're
getting it from their supplements right
well the majority of supplements only
give you like between 49 to at the very
most 99 milligrams per tablet so how
many pillows would you have to take per
day to even get your daily requirement
of potassium well you'd have to have 47
pills okay 47 bills no one's going to do
that if we look at a potassium
deficiency it's often missed it's
omitted because most of the potassium is
inside the cell like 98 so you can't
accurately determine if you have a low
potassium situation just by the blood
because most of the potassium is inside
the cell you would have to do a
different type of test called an
intracellular potassium test not to
mention the symptoms of a potassium
deficiency are sometimes very vague
especially in the beginning you might
have a little bit of weakness in your
diaphragm that affects your breathing a
little bit it's hard to breathe you
might feel a little fatigue you might
have heart palpitations but these are
all just early signs of a potassium
deficiency but eventually as that
deficiency becomes worse you can develop
high blood pressure you can actually
have an increased risk of stroke you can
get fluid retention you can even get
loss of bone and kidney stones because
potassium helps keep calcium out of the
arteries and out of the urine because
sometimes when people get their urine
tested they have high levels of calcium
in their urine which is you know kind of
an environment to form a kidney stone as
you can see potassium is really really
important and it can create a lot of
problems now there's some interesting
reasons why people are deficient that go
beyond just not consuming enough greens
if you take penicillin that can create a
potassium deficiency or diuretics or
steroids or go through chronic stress or
have higher levels of insulin with a
high carb diet another interesting
reason why people are deficient is even
going on the ketogenic diet so let's say
for example you start the ketogenic diet
which is a low carb diet and you're
going into this already deficient in
potassium and you take no potassium
electrolytes or supplements right what
happens is potassium helps you store
glycogen that's that stuff in your liver
and your muscles stored sugar so as you
use that up what comes with that is a
lot of water release and a loss of
potassium as well so if you don't take
potassium when you start the ketogenic
diet you may end up with a potassium
deficiency from that reason but also you
have if you're fasting for like three or
four days right and you don't take
supplements especially electrolytes like
potassium trace minerals or B vitamins
and you're doing this prolong fast you
can start having problems from that not
to mention let's say you fasted for
three or four or five days and then you
eat too much too quickly and then you
also ate too many carbohydrates that's
called refeeding syndrome which is a
severe potassium deficiency now I'm not
going to get into the details but it can
create a sudden shift of potassium from
your blood right into the cell and you
can end up with a serious low potassium
problem which could be dangerous did you
realize that the average person in the
U.S consumes like 60 percent of their
calories from Ultra processed foods
where they strip the nutrients out I
mean let's just take Doritos for example
I used to love Doritos I would consume
huge bags of Doritos in college I mean
just massive amounts and the next
morning I would end up with all sorts of
fluid retention in my fingers and my
feet and at the time I had no
information about health I was the worst
so back then I think they put 11
ingredients in these Doritos and now
it's I think up to 30 ingredients
different flavors that just make it
taste like you're dipping a taco with
hot wings into ranch dressing and so is
there a lot of potassium in Doritos now
there's a lot of sodium in all these
fast food restaurants so it gives you
this flavoring which is kind of
Addicting so you eat too much of it and
then you end up with the potassium
deficiency so all these fast food
restaurants as you see them as you're
driving on the street are just pumping
out empty calories filled with a lot of
sodium very little nutrients if anything
practically zero potassium and you can
see it too if you watch people coming
out of these these restaurants and look
at their eyes it's all swollen around
the eyes they don't look healthy they're
also going to lose the power of their
cellular batteries so they're going to
be walking around tired and each one of
those symptoms will then probably be
addressed by a separate drug so they're
on high blood pressure medication
they're on a blood thinner they're
probably taking high energy drinks and
of course a diuretic for the edema and
the high blood pressure which causes
further potassium deficiencies I
challenge you do this experiment with
your own body start consuming
a lot of high potassium foods okay a lot
of leafy greens just for a week and if
you don't like greens just you can make
shakes blend kale with blueberries
there's a lot of different recipes but
start to increase more potassium-rich
foods and just notice how many of these
problems start disappearing and if you
wanted a really good demo on what this
potassium requirement looks like in
actual food I did a video on that so
check that out I put it up right here